mes chers compatriotes je veux vous
adresser un message de mobilisation
générale ne vous laissez pas voler cette
élection vous avez bien compris le
scénario cynique qu emmanuel macron veut
écrire il veut qu'il n'y ait en face de
lui que les extrêmes parce que les
extrêmes eric zemmour marine le pen sont
son assurance réélection ils ne peuvent
pas à gagner non ne choisissez pas les
extrêmes ne choisissez pas
l'immobilisent choisissez celle qui peut
battre emmanuel macron je serai là
surprise de ce deuxième tour et si
j'arrive à être cette surprise du
deuxième tour alors nous gagnerons cette
élection est alors un autre projet pour
reconstruire la france est possible mes
chers amis je compte sur vous et vous
pouvez compter sur moi
[Musique]